- [Voiceover] We've already
seen that a vector is defined
by both its magnitude and its direction.
What I want to do in this
video is get some practice
calculating or figuring out
the magnitudes of vectors
and I have a vector right over here,
vector u, it is, it is,
visually depicted here on our corded plane
and I wanna figure out its magnitude
and I encourage you to pause the video
and see if you can figure it out.
Well the magnitude of a vector,
just the length of this line
you could view it as the distance
between the initial point
and the terminal point right over there
and so one way to think about it,
you could view this,
the magnitude of the vector,
let me write this.
The magnitude of the vector.
Well you could either think
of it as the distance formula,
which is really, just
comes straight out of the
Pythagorean theorem.
It's going to be the square root of our
change in x squared
plus change in y squared
plus change in y squared.
Once again this triangle,
Greek letter delta is just shorthand
for change in y
and this once again
comes straight out of the
distance formula which really comes out of
the Pythagorean theorem.
It'll become a little bit
more obvious when I draw
the change in y and I draw the change in x
on this diagram.
So what's our change in y?
Well we're starting at our initial point.
We're starting at y is equal to nine
and we are, to get to the y value
of our terminal point,
we're going down to y is equal to two.
So we have a change in y
our change in y is equal to,
going from nine to two,
our change in y is negative seven.
Similarly, our change in x
we're going from x is equal to two,
to x is equal to five.
So our change in the horizontal
direction is plus three.
So our change in x
where we can either think
of this as the horizontal
component of the vector.
This is equal to positive three
and as we've just seen
we have drawn a right triangle
and so we can use a Pythagorean theorem
to figure out, to figure out the length
of the hypotenuse and
you might say wait, wait,
a length of a side of a triangle
can't have a negative value
and that's why these squareds are valuable
because it doesn't matter
if you're taking a negative
seven squared or a positive seven squared,
you're going to get a positive value here
and if you really just
view this as a triangle,
all you care about is
the length of this side
right over here or it's
the magnitude of this side
or the absolute value of it
which is just going to be
positive seven
and so we can say this
is going to be equal to
the magnitude of our vector
so three squared is nine,
nine, and then
negative seven squared is positive 49.
So plus 49
or once again you could view this as our
change in y squared
which is negative seven squared
or you could say,
well just look,
the absolute value,
the length of the side,
we don't wanna think of a side as having
a negative value, the
negative really just says,
hey we're going from the top to the bottom
it gives us our direction,
but if we just say the length of it
it's seven, well you're there
if you just use a Pythagorean theorem.
Seven squared would also be 49
and so either way you get
the magnitude of our vector is equal to
the square root of nine plus 49
is going to be
57, I don't think I can
simplify this radical
too much, no that's it.
So the magnitude of this vector
is the square root of 57.